i mean sometimes kooz is uh  you know  throwing uh not no look pass but look  passes and then like he throws it the  dude catches it and then he looks away  it's like that's that's not how no look  pass works bro  but you know he's still he's still  learning the nuances of of that side of  things  goosebumps gav for a little jump hook he  says he i'm good  47 last year  underneath nettle gets free and kuzma  finds him  harden at that time  left-handed floater gafford all by  himself  there goes vodka  dead whitney  develop great chemistry and friendship  here's kuzma to the cutting bee count  and the foul kuzma right here  that time on a back cut